let's say that we want to figure out
what negative 8 minus negative 2 is now
there's a lot of ways to approach this
but we're going to focus on in this
video is to really build the intuition
and we're going to do that with
something called number chips which you
might have seen before so the first
thing is I'm going to represent negative
8 with number chips
well number chips I can either have a
negative number chip like that or I
could have a positive number chip like
that and if you have one negative and
one positive if you were to combine
these two they could essentially cancel
out to just zero because they are
opposites of each other and we've looked
at that in other videos but let's go to
actually representing this up here so
negative 8 could be represented as eight
of these negative number chips so let me
do that over here so that's one two
three four five six seven
and eight
now if we're subtracting a negative
number this negative number right over
here you could view this as 2 negative
number chips but we're going to be
taking those away because we have a
subtraction right over here so if we
start with negative 8 if we want to
subtract negative 2 we can just take
away two of these negative number chips
so let's just do that and then how many
negative number chips are we left with
we have one two three four five six so
this is going to be is that going to be
6 or negative 6. well these are negative
number chips so this is going to be
equal to negative 6.
now let's up it a little bit and let's
start with something that might seem a
little bit intuitive and once again
there's many ways to approach this maybe
the number chip technique will resonate
with you for building a little bit of an
intuition
let's say we want to figure out 4 minus
seven what is that going to be equal to
well 4 is a positive number so I think
I'm going to use some positive number
chips to represent four I could
represent that as
1 2
and 4
positive number chips
now if I'm taking away seven I could say
hey I'm gonna and I'm taking away a
positive 7 here so that would be
equivalent to taking away seven positive
number chips but I don't have seven
positive number chips here so what could
I do
well I talked before if I have one
positive and one Negative they cancel
out so I can add these pairs of positive
and negative number chips until I get to
Seven so that I can then take them away
so let me do that so I'm going to add a
positive
and I'm going to add
a negative let me make sure I'm doing
that same color
so this once again this is still four
because these two right over here these
cancel out these are just zeros so
you're just left with positive four so I
can do that frankly as many times as I
want and I still have four so let me do
that again
this is still
equal to four because once again each of
these pairs cancel out to just zero and
let me do that again and once again my
goal is to have seven positive number
chips because I need to take away a
positive seven
so let me put the negative right over
here so this is all right over here
equivalent to four it's equivalent to
what we had before but by adding these
pairs I was I now have seven positive
number chips now if I'm taking away a
positive 7
I can take away seven let me just in
another color I can take away seven
positive number chips and I have seven
now so I'm going to take away one two
three four five six seven now what am I
left with well all the positive number
chips are gone and all I have left are
three negative number chips so this is
going to be negative three three
negative number chips is the same thing
as negative three
let's do another example let's say that
I want to do positive 5 minus negative
one
why don't you pause this video and see
if you can do this with number chips
all right well let's first represent
that positive five with five positive
number chips so that's one
two
three
four
and then five
now we're not taking away a positive
number if we're taking away a positive
number we could just take away some of
these positive number chips we're taking
away a negative number so we need to
have negative number chips in order to
take them away so and we're only taking
away one negative one or we're taking
away one negative number chip I should
say so let's add one of those pairs
remember we can keep adding pairs
because it doesn't change the value
because they cancel out so let's add a
pair here this is
one positive number chip and then let's
put a negative number chip right over
there this quantity that's represented
with number chips is still five because
these last two cancel out and you're
just left with one two three four five
the whole reason why I added this pair
here is now I can take away a negative
one that negative one is represented by
this negative number chip right over
here so if I take that away this taking
away negative one that's taking away a
negative number chip and now what am I
left with well I'm now left with one two
three four five six positive number
chips or that's just a positive six